le mandat du fis d'aujourd'hui n'est pas
faire de longs discours pour vous le
présenter parce que d'abord il aimerait
pas ça sachez seulement que ce rimbaud
de la zone qu'on a comparé à brûlant à
brassens à brel a déjà vendu plus de
trois millions d'albums
alors il fait pas tellement de
télévision il n'aime pas tellement ça et
c'est vraiment un scoop qu'il a accepté
de faire scoop à la une alors pas de
longues phrases seulement son blaze
voici renault
bonjour merci merci pour lui alors
renault bonjour bonjour alors tu sors un
disque que dans la nouvelle maison de
disque que tu l'as fait ou se disent que
la forme amériques comme morgane de toi
ou tu la fois en france j'ai commencé
aux états unis je définis ici et tu l'as
fait avec qui je les fais avec des
musiciens américains sauf
l'accordéoniste jean louis roques et
pour les musiques tu as travaillé avec
bucolo jean-pierre bucolo franck
langolff le compositeur de la chanson
pour l'ethiopie ouais et puis et puis
moi moi même et avec jean philippe goude
comme producteur arrangeur réalisateur
tout ça alors il ya une chanson que que
tout le monde entend à la radio un petit
peu c'est ainsi que tu vas chanter pour
la première fois à la télé c'est miss
maguy et une autre chanson qui est très
très bien aussi c'est le retour de la
paix pet
ah ouais ça j'aime bien moi je trouve
alors là tu as fait une grande chanson
c'est une espèce de encore un espèce
d'hommage à boby lapointe
ouais au niveau de l'écriture en ligue 1
espèce d'humour absurde plus un
personnage que cav est déjà bien fait
marrer dans les autos tamponneuses dans
mon dernier disque
oui j'avais pas envie de faire
disparaître comme ça je voudrais que tu
profites du fait d'être à la télé pour
faire le point parce qu'il ya tout et
font qui te regarde et que tu leur
parles un peu de deux trois affaires
récentes dont dans la presse s'est fait
écho mais dont je pense tu t'es jamais
expliqué à la télévision alors la
première c'est cette histoire de moscou
d'y aller à moscou pour chanter tu t'es
retrouvé dans une salle et a chanté le
déserteur et tout le monde sait tirer
alors là quand nous un peu pourquoi
comment bah voila j'ai lancé le
déserteur et tout le monde sait tirer ça
leur a pas plu mais apprendre aux mages
ans on leur a pas plu n'en parlons plus
ouais ils ont noms et tout le monde
s'est tu irais mais en fait il avait
rien compris aux paroles et c'était pas
dès qu'il se sentirait pas ce qu'on leur
demandait de se tirer en quelque sorte
voilà et après qu'est ce qui s'est passé
après j'étais en colère j'étais très en
colère et j'ai craqué j'ai me suis
énervé j'ai dit des conneries j'ai dit
des trucs bien j'ai des trucs tout ça
sous l'oeil noir d'une caméra de qui
était tenue par un pote à moi qui m'a
dit par la suite toute façon ne
t'inquiète pas si tu veux pas qu'on le
montrent ces images on les montre en
rapa
en rentrant à paris je suis retrouvé sur
terre un peu j'ai réfléchi et où je me
suis dit finalement cela colère que j'ai
piqué même si j'en lis pas ce que j'ai
dit ça regarde personne c'est privé ça
j'ai pas envie que 10 millions de
spectateurs voient me vois sortir mes
tripes et flip et angoissé je suis allé
voir mon pote et je lui dis devant de la
scène là dans les loges des poubelles
est touché c'est un scoop je fais passer
le droit à l'information turin est
imaginé mon émission sans cette scène et
où je peux rien à dire et tout voilà tu
accepté que sa belge avait pas choir il
mais c'est pas une émission sur moi
c'était une mission d'information donc
ça faisait partie mais juridiquement
s'était pas je pouvais pas interdire la
diffusion de ce truc au regard du
n'importe quoi alors l'autre chose c'est
l'ethiopie tu as fait ce disque qu'on a
tous adoré avec l'anglais flat langolff
l'or gold
voilà c'était très bien puis après il ya
eu le concert de la courneuve alors là
c'est pareil et moins bien qu'ils
étaient moins bien vrai bah oui c'est
bah oui il s'était moins bien parce que
c'était pas très bien organisé par des
gens dont c'est pas forcément le métier
d'organiser des concerts ça c est fait
trop vite ou ou trop ou trop tôt ou trop
tard ça il n'y a pas eu assez de pub et
puis et puis les gens avaient peut-être
un peu marre aussi de ces de ses
concerts pour des causes
oui toujours bonne et puis et puis je
sais pas mais taper sur sa sur place
c'était bien le dire pour ceux qui
étaient là c'était ça s'est vraiment
passé formidablement le seul problème
c'est qu'il y avait pas beaucoup de
monde quoi fait pas peur de devenir un
peu l'indigné de service non tu te
méfier pas de ça un peu ma fille si je
veux dire je suis assez sollicités pour
faire ou des chansons ou des galas pour
des causes ouais diverses votre racisme
la partie de la misère les nouveaux
pauvres les chômeurs le cancer le sida
et où j'essaye de faire une sélection où
vraiment
forcément arbitraire mais quand je
m'investis dans un truc que j'aime
autant que ce soit de kim viennent du
coeur et les tripes
merci aux non merci